salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique si vous suivez la
chaîne depuis un certain temps vous le
savez si aujourd'hui je me revendique il
ya plutôt des idées conservatrices j'ai
pendant longtemps été mise dans
l'extrême gauche et en particulier
militants anarchistes j'avais commencé
une série de vidéos d'ailleurs sur la
question qui voulez parler de mon
évolution intellectuelle du pourquoi je
m'étais décalé progressivement vers la
droite cette vidéo est bien se sont
arrêtés à la première sur mon parcours
académique puisque après avant de parler
de mon évolution intellectuelle je
voulais faire une série de vidéos qui
parlait de l'anarchisme et de mon
engagement dans cette dans cette
mouvance
et comme toujours quand on a été partie
prenante d'une idéologie il est assez
difficile de la simplifier pour la
rendre accessible à tous du coup
longtemps cette série de vidéos m'avait
un petit peu bloqué et je n'avais pas
fait la suite et enfin aujourd'hui j'ai
décidé de vous faire ces vidéos sur
l'anarchisme et donc vous allez avoir
une série deux de trois vidéos la
première celle ci dans lequel je vais
vous expliquer la théorie des différents
courants anarchiste une seconde nuit
sera plutôt question des la question
organisationnelle et des organisations
anarchistes aujourd'hui et puis une
troisième où je reviendrai sur mon
parcours spécifiquement dans ces
organisations avec une sorte de est bien
de partage d'expériences alors avant de
commencer pour ceux qui seraient pas
très au fait de ces questions dans cette
vidéo j'ai employé le terme anarchiste
également le terme libertaire le terme
libertaire étant un synonyme un petit
peu atténuée du terme anarchistes ont
peut être des esprits libertaires sans
être anarchiste d'ailleurs ce terme
libertaire était à la base le nom qui a
inventé un anarchiste pour nommer son
journal avant qu'il passe dans le
langage commun
donc également petite précision sur ce
parcours pour spoiler un peu sur les
prochaines vidéos j'ai été engagé
pendant une bonne douzaine d'années au
sein de la mouvance anarchiste j'ai
milité dans plusieurs organisations
nationales
d'abord la coordination des groupes
anarchistes pendant cinq ans ensuite à
alternative libertaire pour 34 ans est
également parallèle sans en être trop
convaincu il faut bien l'avouer j'ai été
syndiqués dans un syndicat anarchiste
qui était là la cnt cnt vignolles pour
pour les connaisseurs donc l'anarchie
tel que je le vous présenter aujourd'hui
c'est l'anarchisme tels que quelqu'un
peut le vivre en s'engageant dans le
mouvement est pas une chose très
théorique est très très belle très bien
structuré comme on peut la voir sur une
page wikipédia ou dans un cours à la fac
là on va voir l'anarchisme à telle que
vécue par quelqu'un concrètement on sait
bien que la théorie et la réalité sont
deux pays extrêmement différents
alors tout d'abord l'anarchisme est un
ensemble de courants qui parfois sont
doctrinalement un petit peu opposés
entre londres et paris les plus tôt des
anarchistes mais tous et anarchisme en
continu une base commune dans la vision
qu'ils ont de la société actuelle alors
bien sûr ils sont tous anticapitaliste
puisque le capitalisme a élu comme un
système économique opprimant la majorité
au service d'une petite minorité mais
également les anars ont la spécificité
de voir notre société comme étant une
somme de domination de domination
d'aliénation d'exploitation et
d'autorité indus c'est à dire que
potentiellement pour les anars selon
leur degré d'intégrisme entre guinée et
bien tout lien social d'individu à
individu ou de l'individu au groupe ou
de l'individu aux institutions au sens
large peut-être une
un lien inégalitaire et hiérarchique
avec l'un qui profitent de l'autre ou
qui exploite l'autre par exemple l'école
peut être vu comme une source de
domination parce que le rapport élèves
profs est asymétrique avec un prof qui a
l'autorité du savoir et qui est perçu
comme une autorité totalement
artificielle ou bien
le rapport parent enfant qui peut être
vu comme une domination de l'adulte sur
enfant chez certains ou encore la
religion qui impose des dogmes et des
croyances
aux individus même si depuis plusieurs
années a beaucoup de courants
libertaires met un petit peu la critique
de la religion sous le tapis il faut
bien le dire et puis à côté de tout cela
il y a notamment une institution en
particulier qui cristallise la haine des
libertaires de par son rôle dans
l'organisation sociale et qui est vu
comme étant un petit peu l'archétype de
la domination du lien social verticale
qui impose ses règles individus et cette
institution c'est l'état
l'état est vu comme étant
intrinsèquement mauvais c'est à dire que
contrairement aux marxistes qui qui
considère que l'état est un est une arme
au service du capitalisme pour se
maintenir mais qui peut être détournée à
des fins sociales les anars eux
perçoivent cet état comme étant en soi
une institution de domination
et donc de cette vision du monde les
libertaires tire aussi une vision de la
société future
alors ils sont révolutionnaires qu'ils
veulent bien sûr mettre à bas notre
société actuelle et ils ont tendance
n'est pas à parler de révolution mais de
révolution sociale sous-entendant que
les révolutions du passé en fait étaient
avant tout des révolutions politiques et
ont donc que changer des institutions
mais tout en maintenant les hiérarchies
sociales et donc les anars maintenant en
avant le fait que veulent réellement
tendre vers une véritable égalité
sociale et la société future malgré tout
les variations qu'il peut y avoir entre
tous les courants repose aussi elle elle
même sur des sur de grands principes ce
premier principe c'est le fédéralisme
libertaire dans une société sans état de
fait eh bien il faut tout de même que
les individus les groupes les
entreprises et les communes qui sont les
choix politiques de base pour les anars
puissent interagir entre eux au gré des
besoins des nécessités matérielles
d'infrastructures et puis des choix
politiques faits au sein de ces
collectifs et pour cela il met en avant
cette notion le fédéralisme libertaire
qui permet à toutes ces structures de
s'associer ou de se séparer quand elles
le souhaitent contrairement au
fédéralisme actuel où généralement que
ce soit par exemple des régions des
länder etc sont fédérées d'entre elles
sont à égalité mais n'ont pas de
possibilité est bien de rompre les liens
c'est le veulent et puis le fait ne sont
pas autonomes un autre élément important
pour cette société futur qui sera donc
sans classe et sans état c'est la notion
d'autogestion alors l'autogestion c'est
pas une théorie unifiée c'est une
ensemble un ensemble de pratiques qui
vise à répartir le pouvoir entre tous et
à éviter la création de hiérarchie
sociale alors très concrètement par
exemple personnellement j'étais
lycéen pendant un an au lycée
expérimental de saint nazaire qui était
un lycée autogéré et il n'y avait dans
ce lycée que les élèves et les profs
vous aviez pas tout ce qu'on appelle les
biatoss c'est à dire les secrétaires les
personnes qui font la cuisine qui font
le ménage et c'était lé groupe de profs
et des élèves qui à tour de rôle assurer
ses fonctions ce qui permet d'éviter que
certains se spécialisent dans des
fonctions qui sont valorisé socialement
ou au contraire tout d'autres soient
relégués voilà au balayage qui ait
jamais quelque chose de très valorisant
cette autogestion se base aussi sur la
démocratie directe qu'en cédant le dans
la dans l'entité politique qui est la
leur de base qui est la commune on peut
dire ça ressemble un peu à une forme de
vision un petit peu mythifié de la
démocratie athénienne telle qu'on a sont
les côtés négatifs le réel et dans
l'entreprise bien c'est pareil ce sont
des assemblées générales qui permettent
à tous de décider
de la bonne marche de l'entreprise et la
répartition des tâches alors démocratie
directe ça ne veut pas dire vote puisque
certains anar sont allergiques au vote
vu que parfois on peut se retrouver en
minorité et du coup être minoritaire
chez certains c'est déjà être opprimé
également vous avez une autre notion
dans cette autogestion qui est la notion
de mandat impératif est révocable dans
la société actuelle quand on élit
quelqu'un se soit un maire ou un député
on lui c'est notre parcelle de décisions
pour un certain certain temps il fait ce
qu'il veut avec pendant ce temps imparti
avec le mandat impératif est révocable
l'assemblée générale mandate quelqu'un
pour faire une oeuvre par exemple
construire une école et c'est lui qui va
organiser le chantier les relations
entre entreprises etc et une fois que
cette école sera finie et bien il perd
son mandat il n'a plus de capacité à
créer autre chose et puis révocable
parce que si en cours de route on voit
que sa part en cacahuète
il est incapable de gérer ou que ce qui
fait ne connaissons pas la feuille de
route décider collectivement on peut des
mandatés
donc voilà pour ce qui est des bases
communes à tous les atouts les
libertaires
après donc vous avez des courants
extrêmement différent et je vais vous
présenter ce qu'ils sont les courants
historiques on reconnaît
depuis la naissance de l'anarchisme il
ya un sexe etc et demi alors j'ai pas
vous présenter tout ce qu'on peut
trouver sur internet parce
qu'aujourd'hui il est très facile de
s'amuser à créer des courants en étant
un art qu ait quelque chose derrière
donc vraiment je vais me concentrer sur
les courants historiques auxquels j'en
ajouté un dont on entend beaucoup parler
alors pour situer ces courants j'ai
également utiliser un graphique avec en
abscisse d'un côté le rapport à
l'individu et de l'autre côté le rapport
au collectif
parce que c'est une grande ligne de
démarcation chez libertaire est-ce qu'on
tend vers une société d'individus ou de
sociétés collectives
7 cette ligne des abscisses correspond
aussi à l'intégration des idées
marxistes dans la doctrine libertaire
ceux qui sont plus vers l'individu
refuse complètement et ceux qui tentent
plus vers les logiques collectives et
communistes par contre intègre beaucoup
de logique marxiste enfin deux notions
marxiste dans leur analyse
et puis en ordonnée je vais vous mettre
la question de l'organisation parce que
chez les anars y en a beaucoup qui en
fait refuse de s'organiser
collectivement en partie entre
guillemets ce qu'on appelle
l'organisation spécifique et d'autres
qui au contraire ont développé beaucoup
d'analystes sur cette nécessité de
l'organisation et de l'action collective
cette ordonné sera surtout importante
aussi pour situer différentes
organisations dans la prochaine vidéo
donc historiquement on reconnaît trois
courants libertaires qui sont en fait d
un peu des archétypes des stéréotypes
les positions extrêmes sur
l'idéologie anarchiste vous avez d'abord
les individualistes vous avez ensuite
tous ceux qui se revendiquent d'un point
de vue économique deux sociétés
socialiser c'est à dire une société
communiste
vous avez ce qu'ils disent anarcho
communiste votre anarchistes communistes
ou communiste libertaire alors tout
c'est ce terme renvoie en fait à des
conceptions un petit peu différente on
va voir ça et vous avez enfin les
anarcho syndicaliste
et puis j'ai ajouté
personnellement un quatrième courant qui
n'en est pas un mais qui prend beaucoup
de place aujourd'hui d'un point de vue
médiatique qui est la fameuse et
inénarrable mouvance anarcho-autonome
donc mouvance anarcho autonome qui est
un petit peu comme l'islamo gauchisme où
la notion d'anarchisme de droite c'est à
dire des catégories médiatique dans
lesquelles personne ne se reconnaît
qu'ils n'ont pas vraiment de corpus
non plus mais qui permettent voilà de
l'extérieur on sait qu'ils ont peu à peu
près situe dans cette mouvance même si
de l'intérieur personne ne se revendique
de ces étiquettes
alors tout d'abord l'anarchisme
individualiste c'est un anarchisme qui
est basé
façon très importante sur la notion
d'individu et pour qui en fin de compte
tout lien social quasiment peut être
interprétée comme étant une oppression
même un individu dans un groupe se sent
très vite un peu brille brille mais
[ __ ] par par ce groupe ce sont des gens
qui notamment refuse la notion de vote
parce que donc voter même à 75 ou 80 %
s'est retrouvé minoritaire et donc se
sentir opprimés par les décisions de la
majorité ce sont donc des gens qui d'un
point de vue collectif fonctionne plutôt
au consensus où aller ou à l'unanimité
ce qui dès qu on est dans des groupes un
petit peu
important commence à poser problème
ce sont des gens qui donc comme il
n'aime pas le col et le collectif sont
aussi sûrs pour des formes économiques
très très individuelle libérale entre
guillemets c'est à dire se passe de
petites sociétés de petits artisans ou
de coopératives où les gens travaillent
ensemble mais son petit peu toujours
propriétaire individuellement de ce
crime sont produits
ce soit un petit peu si vous voulez les
les caricatures de l'anarchiste qui est
l'individu qui se rebelle contre la
société contre l'autorité l'individu
seul face aux demandes entre guillemets
ce sont des gens qui ont très souvent
d'expérience un très fort caractère
également vraiment ce côté à côté assez
sérieux ces rebelles d'un individu
rebelles
c'est une vision de l'anarchisme qui de
fait
est assez élitiste entre guillemets
puisque on est plus sur des gens qui
dans cette rébellion individuel s'appuie
sur une sorte de logique de réformes
individuelle plutôt que de révolution
collective
et cette vision quelque part un petit
peu élitiste qui qui ne
s'avoue pas peut aussi dans certaines
conditions faire basculer puisque par
exemple c'est assez individualiste qu'on
doit dans les années 1890 le passage est
bien au terrorisme série qu'on doit
cette image des anarchistes poseurs de
bombes parce qu'à un moment où
l'individu se révolte contre la société
et dans ce qui nous rappelait la
propagande par le fait le geste
d'individus héroïque contre les
dominations ils sont dit que ce serait
bien au moins pour certains de voir de
dépasser jusqu'au terrorisme
alors ça veut pas dire que le terrorisme
art est intrinsèquement liée à
l'individualisme mais voilà c'est à dire
que c'est une vision de l'individu et du
rapport de l'individu et la société qui
à un moment dans certains contextes a
permis un passage à la violence
totalement décomplexée chez certains qui
ont amené certains à l'échafaud mais
voilà qui n'est pas à mener la
révolution pour autant
donc à côté de ces individualiste vous
avez le courant qui est l'opposé des
maîtres allemands qui sont les courants
qui se revendique plus ou moins du
communisme alors les moins
for me entre vous me dire on met le
communisme c'est un petit peu
l'antagonisme de l'anarchisme c'est
l'autorité de l'état etc c'est une
vision du communisme comme étant
toute la société est dirigée par le
parti état c'est en fait un abus de
langage que l'on doit au début du 20e
siècle à l'apparition de l'urss et du
bloc de l'est à la base le communisme
c'est la possession collective par la
société des moyens de production et
après ce qui gère cette société est ce
que c'est un ensemble de fédération est
ce que c'est une assemblée générale est
ce que c'est de l'auto gestion ou un
parti état ça ça c'est la structure
politique entre guillemets donc il ne
faut pas assimiler la notion de
communisme forcément à ce qu'on entend
habituellement en commettant le
communisme étatique chez les libertaires
très clairement vous avez la structure
économique qui sera pour l'instruction
communiste donc socialiser qui
appartiendra l'ensemble de la
collectivité et d'un point de vue
politique vous avez les communes
fédérées qui marchent en démocratie
directe donc on est très loin des
logiques un de l'urss et du parti état
et donc vous avez plusieurs appellations
anarcho communiste communistes
anarchistes ou communiste libertaire
alors grosso modo jusqu'à il ya au moins
quelques années tous ceux qui se
réclamaient anarchistes communistes
anarcho communiste globalement c'était
ce qui était le moins
intéressé par les idées marxistes d'un
point de vue de l'analyse économique et
au contraire généralement ceux qui
disaient communiste libertaire était
incorporé plus de notion marxiste dans
leur analyse et était aussi souvent plus
intéressés par la question de
l'organisation des anars
c'est à dire que en fait
l'anarchisme c'est avant tout une forme
de révolte individuelle qui est peu
structurée et qu'il n'a pas de base de
l'analyse réelle sur la question
économique est donc très vite la
question se pose quand on veut avoir une
vision un peu structurée du monde de la
question d'intégrer le marxisme quoi et
de quelles notions en intègre la lutte
des classes genre de choses et donc
certains on n'intègre plus ou moins et
les
communistes libertaires on n'intègre
plus que d'autres généralement et même
certains vont se dire marxiste et
libertaire
c'est à peu près là dessus que se fait
la distinction avec également la
question de l'organisation qu'on
abordera dans
dans une vidéo ultérieure
et à la fin vous avez également
les anarchosyndicalistes alors les
anarcho syndicalistes se sont
généralement faites des gens qui sont
d'un point de vue de la société future
qui sont communistes libertaires mais
qui diffère des autres anarchistes sur
la question de comment faire la
révolution
les les communistes les individualistes
sont plutôt dans une logique
d'organisation des anarchistes entre eux
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle
l'organisation spécifique le parti entre
guillemets
les anarcho syndicalistes eux estiment
que la révolution doit être faite par le
syndicat comme outil de lutte a redonné
un coussin qui se font plutôt pour
l'action directe c'est-à-dire la grève
générale occupations d usines même
relancé les usines sans le patron mais
il pense aussi que ce syndicat qui est
aujourd'hui une structure de lutte qui
de fait est présente dans pas mal
d'entreprises devraient servir aussi de
futurs tissu de gestion pour le volet
économique de la société
d'ailleurs c'est à dire transformer
l'outil de lutte aujourd'hui avec son
tissu qui est déjà qui est déjà là les
liens qui sont déjà la rentrée
entreprises et bien en anti suggestions
économique dans une société future alors
ça dépend il y en a certains chez qui
cette notion de syndicats qui est
l'embryon de la future société
est extrêmement large comme définition
puisque certains qui j'ai pu discuter
voilà 10 ans recule même tout ce qui est
culturel tout ce qui est
la vie associative etc tout devrait être
gérée par le syndicat et chez certains
ça on a l'impression que on n'a pas un
état partie mais un espèce de d'état
syndicales cette nuit rss syndicales ou
rien dans la ville de la société ne peut
échapper aux syndicats
mais ça c'est un petit peu une vision
extrême mais voilà les anarcho
syndicalistes sont plutôt axés autour de
la lutte économique par le syndicat qui
sera aussi la future embryon de la
future société
et donc à côté de ces courants
historiques il faut aussi éviter la
mouvance anarcho autonome alors la
mouvance anarcho autonome c'est une tout
un monde en soi
vous en avez qui sont plus proches de
l'individualisme et d'autres qui sont
carrément marxiste et qui refuse
complètement les idées libertaires le
point commun à tous les autonomes c'est
que globalement ce sont des gens qui
refusent les toutes les organisations
officielles qu'elle soit réformiste ou
révolutionnaire que ce soit des
syndicats des partis ou des
organisations anarchistes ou de quelque
autre obédience que ce soit parce que
son agent qui estiment déjà que cette
organisation bride d'individus mais
qu'elle les brides aussi dans la façon
de lutter ils ont une espèce de son de
croyance dans la spontanéité des masses
dans les luttes qui vont s'organiser un
petit peu spontanément et être vraiment
radical quand elles ne sont pas encadrés
en fait est ce qui fait que la mouvance
anarcho-autonome entre guillemets
est une mouvance qui est souvent un
petit peu pénible dans les luttes
sociales notamment les luttes étudiantes
ou vous en avez toujours qui vont dans
des assemblées générales
cracher un petit peu sur les syndicats
qui sont dans les luttes et etc et ça
crée toujours des tensions avec les
militants organisés libertaire ou
révolutionnaire en général
on peut quand même faire des sous
catégories dans cette mouvance anarcho
autonome vous avez ceux qui sont
clairement marxiste qui ne relèvent pas
du coup du chant libertaire vous en avez
qui sont
qui se revendique un peu de
l'autogestion genre de choses et vous en
avez également en fait qui a dit faire
parler pratique c'est à dire que vous
avez ce que j'appelle personnellement
les autonomes deschamps c'est à dire des
gens qui sont un peu des néoruraux et
qui vont essayer de tisser des liens
comme ça dans de recréer du lien social
en faisant des activités alternatives
dans en campagne en milieu péri urbain
comme par exemple faire du maraîchage ou
de tenir des épiceries solidaires ce
genre de choses c'est un petit peu ce
qu'elle tentait de faire de fait toute
la mouvance
des gens de tarnac vous savez avec
affaire julien coupat et les siens c'est
un petit peu ce que faisaient ces gens
là en fait et puis vous avez aussi ce
qu'on appelle l'autonomie désirante
alors eux sont du coup très proche d
anarchiste individualiste dans les faits
sont des gens qui sont très centrée sur
les désirs et la réalisation de
l'individu espèce de développement
personnel entre guillemets donc toutes
les questions sociétales
sont généralement et du coup pas du tout
marxiste pour le coup également vous
avez une autre partie de la mouvance
anarcho autonome qui est lié à la contre
culture c'est-à-dire tout le rock
alternatif
certaines pratiques
centres sociaux autogérés ou ou des
squats un petit peu tout ce qu'on
appelle aussi la mouvance anarcho punk
et donc tout ça constitue aussi la
mouvance anarcho autonome et à des liens
toujours plus ou moins étroits avec
certaines parties de l'anarchisme donc
voilà pour ce qui est de l'anarchisme en
soi alors quand on regarde le graphique
que je vous ai fait vous voyez que ben
au milieu il ya rien y'a personne
est en fait s'il ya du monde et la
plupart des anars ne se reconnaissent
pas forcément dans ces courants ces
étiquettes les anars déteste les
étiquettes est en fait une bonne partie
des libertaires se retrouve dans ce
centre mou de l'anarchisme
beaucoup sont un petit peu en fait voilà
sont un petit peu individualiste parce
qu' il aime pas trop
milité dans des groupes propres
importants et puis ils sont un petit peu
contre les organisations cerqual ism
bien s'organiser localement il faut pas
leur parler de se fédérer dans une
organisation nationale parce que pour
eux c'est déjà un parti c'est déjà
oppressif
et puis voilà ils sont pas
individualiste un point de vue
l'économie savent bien qu'il faut un
petit peu de structuration collective
mais ils n'ont pas non plus réclamés
communiste libertaire donc ce qui fait
que vous avez en fait une grande partie
des libertaires qui sont dans ce centre
nous et qui ne se donne pas forcément
des tic est particulière voilà donc en
tout cas pour ce qui est des différents
courants de l'anarchisme passons
maintenant à une petite critique alors
l'anarchisme à quelques problèmes d'un
point de vue doctrinal c'est une
idéologie qui est extrêmement molle
c'est à dire que les pères fondateurs
étaient des hommes d'action avant d'être
des théoriciens ils ont certes écrit des
textes mais grosso modo c'est des textes
qu'on trouve intéressant quand on est
libertaire terre que c'est des gens qui
met des mots sur ce qu'on ressent mais
ce ne sont pas des gens qui ont élaboré
des doctrines ultra précises
c'est à dire que le concept de
domination d'aliénation
d'autorité n'ont jamais été réellement
définit pas ce qui fait que c'est une
idéologie très molle qui s'adapte au
cours du temps puisque les notions de
domination d'autorité varie en fonction
des époques ce qui fait que l'anarchisme
et entrer en résonance avec un peu les
jeunes de mai-68 même si les anars à eux
mêmes les acteurs de l'époque
vous peut même s'en passer totalement à
côté de ce mouvement et ça fait
qu'aujourd'hui et bien l'anarchisme
entre un petit peu naturellement
résonance avec les idées postmoderne ces
lâches wac qui qui parle elle aussi de
domination et quelque part même ces
idéologies j'ai un petit peu comblé le
vide théorique en parlant justement de
discrimination systémique et du coup
viennent un petit peu donner un petit
peu de consistance à ces notions de
de lien social asymétrique et de
domination
alors c'est un avantage et un
inconvénient ça lui permet de s'adapter
et puis quand les idées qui arrivent
sont foireuses comme aujourd'hui c'est
des mots que ça fait que l'idéologie
part en cacahuète
mais du coup ça des côtes est assez
négatif puisque de fait l'anarchisme
n'ayant jamais été structurée et
intellectuellement il n'a jamais
intéressé les intellectuels et ça se
voit quand on compare au marxisme
ddq marque sacré et le marxisme eh bien
vous avez eu tout un courant
d'intellectuels qui s'y est greffée qui
a fait tout le travail intellectuel
classique dans dans le champ idéologique
c'est à dire qui a revisité qui a
réinterprété qui a critiqué qui a
été lié certains arguments et on peut
trouver toute une palanquée
jusqu'aujourd'hui de deux philosophes et
intellectuels qui se revendique du
marxisme ou même des économistes chez
les anars très peu c'est à dire que
comme les pères fondateurs n'ont jamais
rien structurer les seuls qui sont
réellement intéressés à l'anarchisme en
fait ce sont plutôt les milieux
artistiques et culturelles justement
pour ce côté là la beauté du geste de
l'individu qui se rebellent contre le
monde entier
et de fait je suis quasiment incapable
de vous citer de grands intellectuels
qui on puisse réclamer des idées
libertaires pourrait citer par exemple
albert camus ou
michel onfray puisqu'à quelques années
avant son virage droite art et
souverainistes qui a réellement été en
contact avec les milieux militants
anarchistes
mais sont pas des gens qui n'ont plus
conceptualisé beaucoup de choses et qui
n'ont pas affiné les idées qui n'ont pas
rendu les concepts très très opérant
pour comprendre le nom de et donc
fatalement c'est une idéologie qui comme
je voulais dit avec le volet communistes
anarchistes et bien et constamment en
train de se poser la question de
d'intégrer ou non et quelle part de
l'idéologie marxiste on doit intégrer
pour comprendre le monde ça
personnellement je les ai vécus
notamment quand j'avais 23 ans en 2008
avec la crise des subprimes qui à un
moment je me suis senti je me suis dit
mince il faut comprendre un petit peu le
côté économique de notre société et du
coup je me suis naturellement tourné
vers les idées marxistes vers des
abruzzes et du capital etc et je sais
que j'ai pas été le seul à l'époque à
faire ce genre de chemin et à ce moment
là réellement vous voyez en fait la
différence de contenu intellectuel entre
l'anarchisme et le marxisme parce que là
vous avez tout un ensemble de concepts
pour penser le monde alors qu'on soit
d'accord ou non avec ces concepts voilà
comme la lutte des classes
l'extorsion de la plus-value
infrastructures économiques la super
structure politique ce sont quand même
des concepts qui permettent de
structurer une pensée comme toute
idéologie un minimum vertébrés et du
coup vous sentez vraiment la différence
est encore plus quand personnellement
envers 27 28 ans j'ai découvert la
science politique c'est à dire
l'ensemble des courants idéologiques
qu'on a vu en occident depuis
depuis le 2 millénaires là vous voyez
réel manque effectivement
l'anarchisme c'est quand même une
une idéologie qui franchement être un
petit peu bébête il faut dire faut dire
ce qui est et qui est avant tout une une
révolte qui passe dans le champ
politique contestation de la société et
de l'économie
une autre critique que je ferai c'est la
question des tabous parce que
l'anarchisme est une idéologie qui de
fait
veut la liberté étaient tous des
libertés d'égalité absolue on a
l'impression que c'est une idéologie qui
est à une liberté de parole totale or
c'est pas vrai il y a des plein de
sujets tabous
et trois en particulier sur la question
de la prison de l'enfermement du système
judiciaire et de la monnaie c'est à dire
que pour beaucoup danard on basculera du
jour au lendemain d'une société parfaite
qui est de fait une forme de société des
schtroumpfs ou on n'aura plus besoin de
justice plus besoin d'eux
système de
police entre guillemets de milices pour
protéger assure la sécurité de tous et
il y aura plus besoin de monnaie ce qui
fait que c'est une société quand même
assez irréaliste et quand vous présentez
ça des gens extérieurs c'est quand même
assez difficile de leur expliquer et
pourtant quand vous parlez comme ça
d'individu à individu vous voyez vous
n'êtes pas le seul moi je me posais sur
ces questions là on peut pas se passer
de monnaie il ya un moment il faut aussi
penser des systèmes
défense sociale une forme de milice qui
remplace la police quitte à faire des
trucs autogéré puis on peut pas se
passer de l'enfermement de certains qui
seront toujours dangereux quoi qu'il
arrive quoi c'est pas toujours la faute
à la société carreman et bien ça vous
pouvez pas du tout le dire dans les
milieux libertaires si vous osez dire
poser la question de la monnaie déjà on
va vous rire au nez et si vous parlez de
la question de la justice est un
enfermement alors là vous êtes un facho
très clairement
jamais jamais personne ne posera ce
genre de questions dans un débat
structuré et organisé quoi donc ça fait
aussi que l'anarchisme reste cette
idéologie
bébêtes est un petit peu adolescentes
parce qu'il ya ces points la clé qui
souvent ne pas penser
donc voilà pour ce qui était de la
réflexion globale sur sur l'anarchisme
alors également certains du coup me
demanderont peut-être où je me situais
dans cette galaxie alors m'a clairement
je me suis toujours située parmi les
communistes libertaires pas forcément
les plus marxiste loin de là
mêlant ce qui était de le plus axée
autour des questions de l'organisation
on le verra dans la vidéo prochaine de
fait chez les anars ya une forme
d'exemplarité et la faim devant
correspondre avec les moyens et bien la
façon dont on s'organise aujourd'hui ça
préfigure aussi la société future et
donc j'ai toujours été dans ce qu'il
était très axée autour des questions
organisationnelles
mais on verra tout ça dans de prochaines
vidéos et puis voilà cette vidéo vous a
intéressé n'hésitez pas à la partager et
à vous abonner à la chaîne et sur ce que
je vous dis à la prochaine